So this a really beautiful sample of chromium.
So chromium is a transition metal, right in
the middle of the transition metals series
there and it is used to protect metal components
and very often you see chromium plated components
on cars perhaps some of the older cars, you
know, the wheel trims or perhaps the grills
on the front, but if you look at the sample
it is really lustrous, really beautiful and
shiny.
So there are some elements that one is really
fond of and chromium is one of the metals
that I really like. It is a metal you would
have seen it in many places it is used for
plating materials.
This may actually be stainless steel but chromium
looks very similar and it was very popular
for plating bumpers, all sorts of materials
in the 1930s up to the 1950s.
So you can get dull chromium as well which
is where the surface is very bumpy and the
light tends to be absorbed a lot more and
not reflected.
My interest in chromium is that in the chemistry
one of the very first bits of chemistry research
I did in school was involving copper chromate.
I spent months doing experiments on it. I
did not really discover anything about it
but it was great fun. At one stage I had a
whole row of test tubes of copper chromate
above my bed and my bedroom at home and more
recently when I starting doing doctorates,
I did experiments with chromium, making new
complexes of chromium and one of the very
first compounds that my research group ever
made, that was new that nobody else had made
before, was a compound of ethene and chromium
- chromium pentacarbonyl ethene so I have
very warm feelings about it.